[Music]
on this tuesday night battleground
quebec
how the shifting mood in the province
could shape who wins the election and
how the premier here is trying to sway
the vote
jody wilson raybolt in her own words i
have faced discrimination
i faced racism canada's former justice
minister on her new book indian in the
cabinet is this your moment of revenge
political pitches to parents comparing
child care commitments and costs
plus he was bold brilliant and very
funny remember the good old days when
washing your hands didn't take three
hours
remembering canadian comedian norm
mcdonald's
global national with donna friesen
we are in quebec city overlooking the
spectacular chateau front neck built by
the cpr and opened back in 1893 it was
once the tallest building in quebec's
capital there is a lot of history here
and it's quebec's role in the next
political chapter that we are looking at
tonight good evening and thanks for
joining us we are in the federal riding
of quebec and it's one to watch for
decades whichever party that wins here
in the capital has won the most seats in
the province last time the liberals won
this riding but only by a tiny margin
quebec has 78 federal ridings in 2019
the liberals took 35 the block quebecois
32 the conservatives were a distant
third and the ndp won just one riding
going into this election it looks like
there could be dozens of close races in
our top story mike armstrong looks at
what's at stake here
you would be hard-pressed to find a more
open race in the country than this one
the towns that make up the la perry
riding in the last three elections have
swung to three different parties
if there's a wave voters here tend to
ride it
it means people around here have good
taste this man says
province wide quebec can be volatile
there was the orange wave in 2011 the
liberal snapback in 2015 and the blocks
returned to relevance in 2019. pollster
christian book when it comes to federal
elections quebecers are very much
the kings and queens of strategic voting
this time around there hasn't been a
wave but it's fairly clear someone wants
one quebec's premier spent the first
half of the election sort of on the
sidelines everyone wondering if he'd get
involved hey well he did be careful lego
has spent the last week very much trying
to push his supporters in a specific
direction our theme is leadership after
the leaders debates he says quebec
nationalists should avoid the ndp the
green party and the federal liberals
that those parties would tread on
provincial jurisdictions
he's also not pushing e francois
blarchette and the black quebecois mr
blachette cannot form the next
government
the ghost support is squarely behind
aaron o'toole and the conservatives the
question is how much of the electorate
he can sway lugo isn't just the most
popular premier in canada he's one of
the most popular ever
right now absolutely yes for the last 15
months he's had approval ratings close
to 80 percent
which we've never seen we have three
leaders saying that popularity has meant
even the leaders lego has criticized
have resisted fighting back political
scientist danielle bala says lagos push
for the conservatives might help but
they may have started the campaign too
far back they were not doing that well
in the polls so will they get many extra
seats in quebec because of that it's not
sure please help them understand the big
issue in the campaign for quebec
discriminatory laws may end up being
that question in the english debate and
the emotional backlash that followed
she's the referee the premier tried to
turn it into another reason to support
the conservatives but it's the block
that turned the controversy into a bump
at the polls as defenders of quebec it
may turn out to be a gift to their
campaign
no one saw coming
mike armstrong global news montreal
with the election five days away jody
wilson raybould's new book has hit store
shelves once a star in the liberal
cabinet she was canada's first
indigenous justice minister and attorney
general the book is called indian in the
cabinet speaking truth to power in it
she recounts detailed private
conversations with prime minister
trudeau in the final days leading up to
her resignation she writes either the
prime minister knew everything that
happened and did not care and was
clearly lying to me in the country or he
did not know he was either complicit or
incompetent
she says at one point she told trudeau i
wish i'd never met you the snc scandal
also led to the resignations of
trudeau's top adviser jerry butts and
privy council clerk michael wernick and
the ethics commissioner found trudeau
violated conflict of interest rules by
attempting to interfere in the criminal
prosecution of snc lavala
joanie wilson raybull thanks for
speaking with us today let me start by
asking why did you write this book
well i have thought about uh
writing writing this book about my
experiences not only in federal politics
but indigenous politics for for quite
some time and and i found myself like
like many in most of us
being isolated during covet and found it
to be a really a good time for
self-reflection and and to write there's
also a lot of detail about private
conversations you had with prime
minister justin trudeau one of the
things you write is he told me i had not
experienced what i said i did i know he
wanted me to lie this man was not the
leader i thought him to be
so talk to me about the timing of
releasing this is
now just before an election is this your
moment of revenge
well i i
it's not my moment of revenge i don't
think of it in that way at all i'm proud
of of the work that i did and and the
book that has been released today i
want to
and i feel it's important to relay my
experiences i had
announced the publication of my book to
be in the fall of of 2021 and certainly
announced the publication date um
well before
the election was called by by justin
trudeau
what in your view was at the heart of
the clash between you and justin trudeau
was it that you saw the snc matter as a
legal issue and he saw it as more of a
political one that needed to be managed
well i i mean for me and you'd have to
ask
him the same question so he could
reflect on on his views but for me
i mean i am a proud indigenous person in
this country and i have a very different
world view when it comes to addressing
issues i mean some might say that i
am naive in talking about this but i
truly believe
that we can and this is an overused line
do politics differently what message do
you think your story in federal politics
sends to women especially indigenous
women about their future role as leaders
in politics
i'm hopeful and and
i remain hopeful and i'm not
even though i
have some mixed emotions and reflections
on my experience in federal politics and
one of those is that i'm sad and that
sadness comes from
the lost opportunity
to
do what we said we were going to do
when we came when this government came
into power in 2015. i have faced
discrimination
i faced racism around the cabinet table
marginalization of my voice even though
i
have
lived experience and expertise in
particular subject areas
i know that this is an experience that
many women and individuals have in their
work lives do you still consider
yourself a liberal and are you willing
to tell us how you voted no i'm not
going to tell how i voted but um you
know i had never been a member of a
political party in in my entire life
that's not part of the way i think about
the world in terms of compartmentalizing
individuals in terms of labels the
liberal party under justin trudeau is
certainly not something that i
understand or align with i hope that my
experience and it was painful
at times
it was emotional certainly it was joyful
and i through writing this book you know
did as they say
i went on a bit of a it was a healing
process for me i look forward to to
figuring out what that best the best
place is for me
to continue the work that i've done my
life my entire life
okay jody wilson ray bold thank you
thanks for having me
we talked about a lot more you can hear
the full interview on globalnews.ca
global national well voters are running
out of time to make their choice and
it's unclear if the partisan personal
jabs between liberal leader justin
trudeau and conservative leader aaron
o'toole will motivate voters or turn
them off when things get personal it is
a clear sign of a tight race and as
abigail beeman reports trudeau is
sharpening his antio tool messaging in
the final stretch
the biggest problem mr o'toole has
is that
he doesn't
lead
he misleads sharper attacks in the final
week he can't get his candidates
vaccinated he can't explain why he
thinks it's okay for non-fully
vaccinated candidates to be going to
seniors homes the liberals have been
building their campaign to drive home
the message of a two-person choice it
does
make a difference
whether or not there's a conservative or
a liberal government polls have been
tight from the start increasing pressure
for this final stretch the idea that the
liberals are actually under pressure to
even win the plurality of seats in this
election campaign is really is really
clear political experts say a particular
challenge for the liberals will be
getting out the vote due to residual
annoyance with an election many still
feel is unnecessary plus the pandemic
effect i think what's different this
time and it hurts the liberals is that i
think we're gonna have lower voter
turnout one liberal minister in a tight
bc race pushed back on that we're not
seeing that no people are pretty engaged
now campaign sources say they will be
targeting a lot of tight races with
seats they think they can either pick up
or hold on to including many seats they
lost in 2019 and the pace of the already
fast moving campaign will pick up too
starting his day in b.c tuesday trudeau
makes another stop in ontario's gta
before ending the day in atlantic canada
abigail beeman global news richmond bc
the conservative leader has called out
justin trudeau several times for calling
an election during the pandemic today
erin o'toole was also touting the
conservatives plan for a refundable tax
credit for child care
today i announced my plan to secure
child care for canadian families to put
parents back in the driver's seat when
it comes to choosing the kind of options
that work best for their kids
to help lower income families today
not five years from now with up to 75
percent of child care expenses covered
child care expenses can eat up a large
chunk of a family's budget it can
sometimes make more financial sense for
one parent to stay home all the parties
know families need help tonight ann
gaviola looks at the promises for child
care quebec's subsidized day care system
has enabled many parents to work and
that's been good for them and for the
economy boosting parents participation
in the labor force has helped grow gdp
but in other parts of the country
parents still struggle you know i was
trying to work from home and so was my
partner you know and you know zoom calls
with the toddler and prescott on your
head you know those sorts of things uh
you know it was really tricky for
carolyn ferns child care has been hard
to find and expensive the wait lists the
uncertainty the fees
and you know that we really need to work
together for something better political
observers suggest this election is a
referendum on child care the liberals
and ndp pledging to move forward with a
10 a day plan at a cost of 30 billion
dollars
if implemented it could save an average
family in toronto nearly 20 000 a year
calgary almost 13 000 and halifax nearly
9 000 annually eight provinces have
already signed on but not two of the
biggest ontario and alberta the
conservatives say they'll scrap the
liberal plan and instead implement a
refundable tax credit aimed at helping
lower income families the price tag 2.6
billion over five years o'toole's plan
could be implemented quickly and
wouldn't cost as much but the scope of
those it helps may be more limited every
program as
as custom benefits and and the benefits
society of subsidizing child care
i i believe are are pretty substantial
after examining both plans economist
gordon cleveland concludes the liberals
have a far better plan for making child
care affordable while the conservatives
tax credit would only have a minor
effect on affordability
there is a growing consensus about what
might be the best most impactful
approach for canada and it mirrors the
path already being taken in quebec which
offers affordable subsidized child care
like the liberals and the ndp are
proposing as well as a tax credit like
the conservatives you might call it the
best of both worlds ann gaviola global
news toronto
we'll have extensive coverage on monday
on election night right here on global
television as well as on history global
news radio and globalnews.ca
it was a one-of-a-kind comic coming up
fans mourn the loss of canada's norm
mcdonald
quebec is an algonquin word meaning
where the river narrows we are on the
traditional unseated territory of the
huron wendat people
we're back in a moment
mr littles what are you doing
yeah i found this backstage oversized
hat funny
sad news about canadian comedian norm
mcdonald it's been revealed he had
cancer he kept it private for years and
macdonald has died at the age of 61. he
was born in quebec city he did thousands
of hours of stand-up comedy all over
north america and went on to saturday
night live mcdonald was revered as a
comedian's comedian while making the
rounds on late night shows tributes are
pouring in including from conan o'brien
who said i will never laugh that hard
again i'm so sad for all of us today
linda o'leary the wife of celebrity
businessman kevin o'leary has been found
not guilty of careless operation of a
vessel after a deadly boat crash in
august 2019 o'leary was driving a boat
across lake joseph north of toronto it
collided with another vessel two people
on the other boat died the crash
happened at night the judge found the
other boat did not have navigation
lights on the judge also rejected
arguments alcohol and speed may have
been factors
ahead ontario's western university on
edge as a string of violence starts the
school year
just days into the academic year
ontario's western university has been
rocked by violence and allegations of
sexual assaults a first-year student has
died and social media has exploded with
reports of women being drugged at a
party on campus micro lay on what we
know about the incidents and the police
investigation
western university's reputation is no
secret for students it's a great school
that also knows a good party the first
thing my parents pretty much said to me
when they dropped me off was like be
careful go in groups western welcomed
back students this past week and almost
immediately was hit with violence and
tragedy first-year student gabriel neal
who dreamt of becoming a doctor died
after he was violently assaulted near
campus a 21 year old man has been
charged with manslaughter
police are also investigating at least
three reports of sexual assault on
campus involving four women and possible
sexual violence at a 600 600-person
first-year student residence
and one out-of-control party saw police
pelted with bottles this weekend
london's mayor is livid
what the hell
are they thinking
none of this is okay and it can't be
swept underground or ignored but not
every incident has been reported at
least not to authorities unverified
posts circulating on social media allege
a group of young women attending a
residence party were targeted i've heard
that 30 girls in this residence were
drugs
and i've seen first-hand girls throwing
up
and
a girl on my floor got
just terrible things were happening the
london abused women's center tells
global news it has received a handful of
calls from alleged victims jennifer dunn
says it's alarming but sadly not
surprising i think that there's a
culture problem at every university
western is in the news right now but
next week it could be
york university right western is in the
news right now there is a problem but
that stems from a bigger systemic
problem that needs to be addressed
police say they want to address it but
they first need students to talk to them
microlight global news toronto
up next the pandemic has been hard on
tourism in quebec city why that is
beginning to change
you're looking at the mighty mo moral
falls we'll be right back
quebec city's history extends back
thousands of years the first inhabitants
here were indigenous people and it is
one of the oldest european settlements
in north america visitors from all over
the world come here or at least they
used to when the pandemic hit everything
stopped and now the city is trying to
get back on its feet
you can feel the longing to get back to
normal do you feel ready after
months of the pandemic to have a
red is vacation
the word for it
this couple is from calgary among the
thousands of tourists who have come to
quebec city the summer was busier than
expected the canadian and quebec market
and the americans are coming back as
well but there really was an amazing
demand in the city this year but for
some businesses the wait has been too
long especially in old quebec where they
rely on tourists for rent signs are
everywhere
there's a good crowd in this cafe but
like in so many places across the
country they are short of staff limiting
how many tables they can serve
hotels have the same dilemma the tourism
industry is fragile and the pandemic
isn't over making it hard to plan one of
the surprises that we had was the level
of challenge that we're having caused by
the labor shortage which is impacting
volumes and revenues allowing fully
vaccinated international tourists in has
really changed the game in terms of
demand
and here in quebec everyone must show
proof of vaccination to go to places
like restaurants even to sit on the
patio how do you feel about that
i've got no problems i mean i know that
everybody here is immunized and so
the cases of covet coming out from here
will be nil to none so
i feel really comfortable and that's
what
really attracts us to this place and
i wish alberta would adapt the passport
it is the ticket to feeling safe
allowing visitors to happily bask in the
last race of summer
and that is global national for this
tuesday from quebec city i'm donna
friesen that's dufferin wraps around the
chateau frontenac just one of the
beautiful spots here you won't regret a
visit
thanks for watching jeff semple will be
at the anchor desk tomorrow and i'll see
you again on thursday from brampton
ontario take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
oh
[Music]